>> LAURA: THE ANTI- TRUMP
FORCES IN THE MEDIA ARE
PRETENDING TO BE REALLY
DISTRAUGHT ABOUT YESTERDAY IS
RECOGNITION OF THE MATTIS.
THE ONLY ADULT HAS LEFT THE ROOM
.
YOU YOU'VE HEARD THE ECHOES,
BEWARE, TAKE THE POLITICAL
EARTHQUAKE IS ROLLING THROUGH
WASHINGTON AND THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION SINKS FURTHER
INTO CHAOS.
>> THERE ARE NO MORE GROWN-UPS
IN THE ROOM.
>> THE RETREAT ACROSS THE GLOBE
AND THE MOST EXTRAORDINARY
RESIGNATION IN MODERN AMERICAN
HISTORY CERTAINLY IN THE PAST 4
YEARS.
>> THE DEMOCRATS ON THE HILL FO
TEN YEARS ARE DEMANDING OUR
TROOPS COME HOME FROM IRAQ THEY
NOW SOUNDS LIKE THEY WENT TO TH
SCHOOL OF FOREIGN POLICY.
>> I THINK THIS WILL BE
CONSIDERED ONE OF THE WORST
FOREIGN-POLICY BLUNDERS OF THIS
CENTURY.
CERTAINLY OF THE CENTURY TO DATE
.
>> NO ONE KNOWS WHY THE
PRESIDENT IS MAKING THIS
DECISION TODAY VERY.
>> THE DECISION MADE IN OUR
CAVALIER FASHION A DECISION THA
IS DANGEROUS.
>> LAURA: DIDN'T THEY ELECT
OBAMA, NOT ONE, BUT TWICE BASED
ON HIS PLEDGE TO BRING THE
TROOPS HOME?
>> FOR THE LAST DECADE WE SPEND
A TRILLION DOLLARS ON RISING
DEBT AND HARD ECONOMIC TIMES.
NOW, WE MUST INVEST IN AMERICA'
GREATEST RESOURCE.
OUR PEOPLE.
THE INVASION THAT CREATES NEW
JOBS IN INDUSTRIES WHILE LIVING
WITHIN OUR MEANS.
AMERICA, IT IS TIME TO FOCUS ON
NATION BUILDING HERE AT HOME.
>> I WANT TO STAND UP AND CHEER.
IN FACT, AT ONE POINT TOP
DEMOCRATS WERE CRITICIZING OBAM
FOR THE SLOW PACE OF HIS TROOP
WITHDRAWAL.
>> MANY OF US WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THIS GO FASTER THAN THE PATH
THAT WAS LAID OUT, HOWEVER WITH
THE PROPER PROGRESS WHETHER IT'
ON THE CIVILIAN SIDE OR ON THE
GOVERNMENT SIDE, THE
ANTICORRUPTION SITE, IT MAY WEL
BE THAT WE COULD HAVE A QUICKER
DRAWDOWN.
>> VERY IMPATIENT FOR THE DRAW
DOWN THERE.
WHEN DONALD TRUMP IS PRESIDENT
ALL THE OLD PRINCIPLES OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY PLAY OUT THE
WINDOW.
FURTHER I THINK IT WISE TO FOCU
ON THE SUBSTANCE AND THE LETTER.
THE STRENGTH OF OUR NATION IS
LINKED TO THE STRENGTH OF OUR
UNIQUE AND COMPREHENSIVE SYSTEM
OF ALLIANCES.
WE CANNOT PROTECT OUR INTEREST
ARE SERVED THE ROLE EFFECTIVELY
WITHOUT MAINTAINING STRONG
ALLIANCES ENJOY AND RESPECT TO
THOSE ALLIES.
BEFORE WE RUSH TO ENGRAVE THOSE
WORDS ON A TABLET IN
INDEPENDENCE HALL WHICH THINK
ABOUT THE CLAIM THAT APPEARED
WHILE HIS DEEP AND ABIDING SENS
OF SERVICE IS INSPIRING, THE
ARGUMENT THAT AMERICA'S STRENGT
IS IN OUR ALLIANCES KIND OF
STANDS IN CONTRAST TO WHAT ARE
FRAMERS BELIEVED.
I READ WORST GEORGE WASHINGTON'
ADDRESS ON THE.
ALL AMERICAN SHOULD READ IT, I
THINK AT LEAST A FEW TIMES A
YEAR.
IT IS STUNNINGLY BEAUTIFUL, IT'
WISE, IT'S HUMBLE, AND IN MANY
WAYS IT'S PROPHETIC.
MATTIS IS A GUY STEEPED IN
MILITARY HISTORY.
HE KNOWS THAT WASHINGTON WARNED
AGAINST ENTANGLEMENTS ABROAD
THAT WOULD PUT OUR NATION AT
HOME AT RISK AND IT WOULD NOT
SAFEGUARD THE COMPANY THE
COUNTRIES.
HE SAID IT'S HER TRUE POLICY AS
DEAR CLAIR A PERMANENT ALLIANCE
OF ANY PORTION OF THE FOREIGN
WORLD.
IT IS HARD TO TAKE THAT AND NOW
THAT'S WHAT WASHINGTON SAID.
THOMAS JEFFERSON ECHOED THE SAM
SENTIMENT AND HIS OWN INAUGURAL
MESSAGE.
HE SAID PEACE, COMMERCE, AND AL
OF US FRIENDSHIP WITH NATIONS
ENTANGLING ALLIANCES WITH NONE.
WASHINGTON ALSO WARNED US TO
AVOID THE NECESSITY OF THE
OVERGROWN MILITARY
ESTABLISHMENTS WHICH UNDER ANY
FORM OF GOVERNMENT ARE
INAUSPICIOUS TO LIBERTY AND
WHICH AREN'T TO BE REWARDED IS
PARTICULAR HOSTEL THE REPUBLICA
LIBERTY.
THE POINT WOULD BE DRIVEN HOME
161 YEARS LATER BY PRESIDENT
EISENHOWER AND HIS OWN FAREWELL
ADDRESS HE SAID WE MUST GUARD
AGAINST THE ACQUISITION OF
UNWARRANTED INFLUENCE WHETHER
SOUGHT OR UNSOUGHT BY THE
MILITARY INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX.
I AM NOT HERE TONIGHT TO SAY WE
SHOULD WORK WITH OTHER COUNTRIE
OF COURSE WE DO AND WE SHOULD
AND WE SHOULD LIVE UP TO OUR
COMMITMENT TO HELP OUR ALLIES.
BUT IT'S ALSO THE CASE THAT WER
NOT IN A FINANCIAL POSITION TO
REV UP THE WORLD POLICE SQUAD
EITHER.
MADDOX SAID HIS HEAD INCLUDING
IN HIS RESIGNATION THAT WE CAN'
BE THE PLACEMENT OF THE WORLD.
WHENEVER WE TAKE ACTION ABROAD
ESPECIALLY MILITARY ACTION, IT
SHOULD BE BASED ON CLEARLY
DEFINED GOALS.
WITH A SPECIFIC SECURITY
OBJECTIVE WHICH ALLOWS FOR AN
AMERICAN WITHDRAWAL FROM THE
REGION.
THE ARGUMENTS FOR SO MANY AS WE
CAN PULL OUR TROOPS OUT BECAUSE
THEN CHAOS WILL ENSUE.
WELL, BY THAT THINKING WILL
NEVER LEAVE ANYWHERE WE DEPLOY
BECAUSE CHAOS IS ALWAYS A
POSSIBILITY ESPECIALLY INTO
MODULUS PLACES LIKE THE MIDDLE
EAST.
DONALD TRUMPS FOREIGN-POLICY IS
BASED IN PRINCIPLE REALISM.
NOT ENDLESS INTERVENTIONISM.
WE HAVE NO PRESSING NATIONAL
SECURITY INTEREST IN SYRIA NOW